were so full podcast welcome to the were
so full podcast we're here every Friday
morning or afternoon or whenever
Lisa Esparza puts out the podcast she's
a busy woman
we got Rodrigo Torres the co-host of the
year yeah man how you guys doing out
there we're doing good bro man let's
just start ranting right now oh yeah I
ran you gonna start I'm just tired of
Bush's time what you tired of bro what
am I tired of I'm trying to the [ __ ]
Heat Dawg I swear to God I couldn't
[ __ ] stand this summer I wasn't
[ __ ] go crazy dawg all right have a
seat dog like a little Eskimo tired of
people man
sending me phones me bro oh no who the
EFA's me Neil a traitor's some he phones
me you know you guys support you know
someone starting a small business you
know sort of taco truck they're gonna do
this you're gonna do something you know
but these are you [ __ ] me I thought it
was ran it was my husband I've been
working for 20 years supporting his
family making sure that we have enough
clothes making sure that we have enough
to eat paying the rent on time and he's
never taken a vacation
damn and we're asking for $7,000 that's
it so to take him and myself and our
three kids on a trip to Hawaii
that's all you that's the only one yes
so can you please share this and let all
your friends know that my husband he's
been through a lot something I want to
say their name let me tell you something
[ __ ] I know 20 years your husband
couldn't saved up a hundred dollars yeah
what's a hundred times 20 bro 20,000
yeah [ __ ] that man dogs I'm not even
gonna lie how much okay never mind then
you can say the morning that my
microphone my my headphones hello
I ran back all right man yeah man in
those years you know you could have
saved up money in 20 years right
what kind of four capable what kind of
our 4k plan they have at that job or
whatever is called for one plan you
don't know I never had a job like that
come on twenty years dude put some put
some weight I mean where were these
people before you funny but we're worthy
Eddie [ __ ] spending money begging
their family nobody cares
come on you got a little bit of clout
dude over there [ __ ] you're trying to
ride those [ __ ] uh followers I
support you funds me you know one is
when it's real like when I feel like
it's legit like a bunch of kids wanna go
play baseball in each travel money
because they made it this far and you're
gonna go travel and don't have plane
trips and they selling enough barbecues
I don't any money for that that's cool
the Ventura a woman's Football League
you know a woman's probably didn't mind
the fees got raised so they could the
Wolfpack of Ventura they couldn't raise
the money to to play on their field are
not sure yes what do I don't any some
little money and for that you know
without those naughty naive fund me did
you put it out on Facebook have you read
any crazy ones
dude just [ __ ] not not anything like
ridiculous like that as far as somebody
wants to go on vacation but that's extra
curricular activities dog if somebody
needs like a leg or something I get it
dog you know I read another one that I
said that she said that um oh she said
that um go for that she's been living in
her house for a long-ass time and take
care of her family and her mother died
you know a lot of problems bro a lot of
problems a lot of problems but let's get
you the money first
she needs $25,000 to save her home
because it's gonna go up for sale in
like two months and let me tell you
something man it's not enough money in
the world I can I saved that house if
you don't know how to manage your money
you know so we're gonna give you $25,000
you know go up to our buy your house
back come on man you're only gonna come
over 25,000 there's other people they're
gonna show up to buy your house with
200,000 gonna show with a million
they're gonna over bid you $25,000 um
yeah we like to bid 25 thousand dollars
to buy our house 25 25 25 million twice
yeah 45,000
man we should have asked for more money
55 done I know I've been through some
hard times real hard you've always cope
though how I cope bro I'm having some
hard time bro we're like I know that
that I when they even before last
comment and I knew that there has to be
a budget you know but good without a
budget you don't have nothing I don't
know if Alisa but I even before I met
her I knew that I needed a hundred
dollars a week tattoos buy weed I have
to have either a hundred you know to get
the party started
so I would howl so hard bro hustle hard
hangover human [ __ ] yeah you were on
your head like that when you were
slacking well Ivan but there's time I
think I couldn't pay the rent bro but I
started telling jokes well you made it
happen though right yes I dude I mean
dude I've had to sell my records dog to
[ __ ] they ran dog and a little bass that
I had all just [ __ ] up [ __ ] I remember
you so the base table I know the records
yeah I had her sell the records too cuz
I do what am I gonna go go to my mom and
dad's house and beg for money [ __ ] that
whoever my brother and for there's
something like that there's like when
there's family members who are who are
like I never been that guy I think only
one time dude I ain't gonna lie I was
cracked out and I mean some dude for my
hood
he gave me money like hey money might
give me like money he gave me drugs to
sell he told me that what to give him
back a certain amount but at the end of
the night I think I smoked it all or
spend the money bro and then he have the
money so this was a guy that could
easily beat up but I don't want to go
that route you know I wanted to pay him
so bro I man embarrassing my mom was
working at the elementary school a
second Street and I won't know and then
she was working with a bunch of kids you
know playing basketball right foo I went
over there crashed out dirty and I asked
my MA she could love me $60 she give it
you yeah and there was guess what what
happened they didn't pay the guy keep
the party going
what a loser bro problem oh my god I
wouldn't want to go buy drugs in some
other neighborhood so they won't know
where I was but damn right we were right
guys it was practically like I was lying
dog me when I'm a dad had to fork it
over
she wouldn't give it to you anyways but
is this young Felipe it's like after his
twenties Felipe okay me when I'm I
thought I'm gonna get they're gonna kill
me and um you know like you know she was
[ __ ] like who's gonna kill for 60
bucks
I even know how to big dog and what and
they know it
it was some guy they called trigger he
got shot he got killed
no he got killed after the rehab but I
remember like he came he came looking
for me and I thought he was gonna like
get physical but keep in mind man I
could beat this guy up but I just didn't
want to look bad you know in front of
him but I remember man going you know
it's funny when you're a crackhead man
you want to know how crackhead really
works watch Sam or Jackson in a jungle
fever that like Tibet let the way he
acts in front of his mom for money
that's the way my brother acted and
that's the way I acted
I got to the school and first of all I
play it all that I was there to help her
right start picking up balls yes I'm
picking a ball starting game the kids
playing with them getting my heart rate
going [ __ ] and then we're ready to grow
with dark I told myself I'm either
borrow shitty they can give you the
money I'm gonna take her purse Oh school
oh my god you already had that one so I
started playing with the kids first oh
yeah daddy [ __ ] but then I got the cash
fifty bucks and I remember I didn't pay
that fool yeah instead of going down you
went back up again yeah that was that
time bro that was that time I don't
think I remember another time where I
had to really like bang you ever uh you
ever saw blood plasma fool I tried I
stopped I sold more than twice my
[ __ ] breeding at that BT good
bring that Bluff full of sugar bro me
and the e knows it will Ronnie Eno's me
say their names but yeah there they were
Native Americans uh-huh
shadow to primo Pima Papago tribe out of
Tucson Arizona Pro this was totaled yeah
Batman yeah Batman I know this place
what there on Main Street where you
could donate blood plasma I'll kind of
share cartilage I don't know though
biopsy I was on Main Street and and
right now bro if you go to that Main
Street it used to be like I'll get my
movie theater they're sold porns I think
the last real gradually they showed
there was um was Raging Bull damn that's
the last good movie I feel like they
show porns but now they show it's an
independent movie in the independent
film so that place I was all blue and
they have blood right there right and
wait I didn't know that you have to be
sober to donate blood yeah you can be
all sucio bro nah we get there the most
close bro and it was like $20 for plasma
and like 30 bucks to donate blood come
back here tomorrow Lee
I was ready dogs but on the way home we
ended up jacking somebody and then we
found some but somehow we both always
find a way you know like somehow if I
don't way to get to get higher so I
wouldn't have a budget man getting back
to the budget then I met Lisa and she
really know how to budget bro like a pie
graph is [ __ ] I grab black we got this
money and she would like come home what
it was before we're living together but
I'm I knew like she would get all her
tip money together from the Laugh
Factory or the ice house wherever she
was working and a lot of cash bro Papa
Papa
rack it up stack it up but I sure bring
it down okay this is going for some of
my rent this is going for this is going
for that I don't know people don't do
that huh nah dude I never did that
before when over like working with Gabe
there's no gettin paid I just knew that
I had to pay my rent and that's it so
I'll put that money inside but I never
saved anything yeah for anything else
you do they used to show to you in like
high school dude little fool they don't
do that [ __ ] anymore or your parents the
initial real high school the old school
that you know better how to balance a
checkbook dude nah man nobody taught me
nothing
yeah learned that shouldn't retail
marketing dawg Dave Jones but that was a
monkey's name of a teacher
[Music]
well you haven't talked about it they
lost you know oh man
it was taboo that little shorty dog
Altuve men I went to game what would the
game five season game six they won
What's Up boo [ __ ] some photos of a man
come on shoot away man machine gun this
bro yeah I thought Stevie click man I
freely oh [ __ ] the studio in a corner
Felipe well that's right I love when you
don't return someone's calling they call
you on and all like a destroyer there
hey man you didn't call me back
yeah well I hate when it gives away my
phone number and using that my number
and then they call bro right away who
are you bro I call it wait checking
right away you really want to call me
check the full and we're tell me what
you want now always time when somebody
goes a man who talk to you no he don't
man even [ __ ] message hey I don't
need to talk to you bro you ain't no
manager you ain't bringing no money into
my life
you [ __ ] John what the [ __ ] you want
now yeah yeah won't talk to you about
something I don't there's nothing to
talk about bro we were talked in years
get johnny-come-lately dawg yeah man or
or a man yeah I mean it
Felipe I'm a but thinking about man we
should collaborate on this collaborate
bro well the last thing you know
something yeah
stay there so what with a notepad with
nothing on it bro collaborate means let
me jump on your hot yeah right now hey
you got [ __ ] going on hey I love your
work back you get Bill burr to come to
our show - yeah that's a classic one
right that's the classic they call you
up and they go like and then they don't
even ask you to do their show
okay go hey this guy this guy called
this guy called me a couple weeks ago
he's like yeah you think I could you
could ask Burt Burt I can open for him
like a dude I'm [ __ ] dad I went for a
callback
yeah hey can I take a photo do you know
Neil crazy hey buddy oh this is a
classic one right here man I got I got
one I got a callback one time anything I
stayed up amen
you still have a line on gabriel
iglesias yeah [ __ ] him
now no I have no line for him yet but
they want the only one I'm the one he
wanted him bro it like like some guy he
wanted he's gonna he's gonna have a
comedy show to antara improv with some
wrestlers yeah and we're gonna have like
a bunch of wrestlers we're comedians
right and I know our father tell you I'm
right here [ __ ] I know I need
the [ __ ] gig they just run show oh
yeah and then and then they wonder when
you get a little success how can you
know which on the corner Maury my father
you had a chance or what's up with
comedian call me one time amen are you
interested in making seven G's yeah bro
call call Barry cats
oh I remember when I should just call
you that's right bro we were dealing
with 60 bucks back then yeah yeah oh
honey with $100 when Hollywood on yeah
man yeah man
trust the comedian was with a 77g gig
I'm asking how did you get it bro maybe
they get paid fifteen thousand and
you're trying to keep eight [ __ ] yeah
yeah alright the truth
yeah the skimmer the skimmer yeah I
don't mind the skimmer if I'm making the
money - yeah yeah like what time I did a
guy a gig all week broad did seven show
yeah a week I got $1,500 and back there
bro I had no money I was happy to take
the gig he flew me out
well when they paid us on the first show
Chico State University yeah the check
was by grad yeah yeah he got pissed off
because it gave me the check oh yeah
you're opposed to see that see what bro
but don't worry about it bro you told me
1700 I said 15 no combo you say 1700
right now dawg
I would leave da no contract there's no
paper binding me to this game yeah so
listen man you're making I know you're
making now 5,000 so I'm making them
you're making fight outta here you're
making fight other the next day you know
you make it public thirty thousand a
week
yeah I was saying that in my head yeah
but um oh you know I was happy to make
the fifteen hundred oh yeah yeah well I
agreed to it you know I agreed to that
but it's different when you get there
and it's fifteen hundred and they go man
you know what man oh the worst I showed
up to the club and in there the flyer to
the gig J Scott here that old can you
work with me yeah can you work with me
the I bone shows before man where all
the Flyers are in the green room and
nobody passed out [ __ ] oh man I was in a
van full of flyers bro right into the
gig yeah I got picked over the airport
[Laughter]
ban on way to a gig I had a guy one time
he goes hey can you do the headliner
spot I can't make it I go yeah guys the
guy's gonna give me an envelope
don't open it up just give it to me and
I'll pay you the brother open it
you little Dell Rhea's Ryu aha winner is
you open envelope and put a note in
there you should pay more nobody knows I
just held it up to the light and I was
like this bastard I should do gigs blow
it where's people will tell me man that
gang is gonna I'm paying you or $200 but
when you get there they're gonna give
you 800 yeah just slap me six people
don't know but a good winner about the
Hylian comedy cartel bro it's like um
it's like everybody it so everybody's
okay with it to you George saying
somebody oh yeah oh yeah if you just
give them [ __ ] while he desert well he
wanted well he you put together right
yeah you read follow something you ever
follow somebody all mostly all named
Cisco my podcast I learned so much about
the rooms that [ __ ] scam they're like
a [ __ ] paramount and those $75 gigs yeah
things like [ __ ] that guy and Seattle
that I'll pay you way to the airport all
this guy's mad or Pierce talk will this
or so tell you know you go to a gig and
it's super PAC and you're like what yeah
I was on a flyer this is a fundraiser
and then like yeah man sometimes I'm
nothing letting people do for how many
fundraisers am I gonna do this year yeah
yeah they'll shake and fake fundraisers
and where you're like what's this one
for
oh it's my son school and there you go
will you do this every month
yeah I mean what the [ __ ] going on
here we're just talking about that man
like we were just talking before you got
here we were talking about ephone me
like where were you before you phone me
with hear me yeah what'd you do you know
who are you trying to scam huh you know
like I was telling their I support you
funds me like if it's a friend who's
trying to start do we don't want our
special
right you know or here the movie coming
out he tried to produce his own movie or
do something but there's but there's
like offends me you know for people who
are not in the music industry or the
film industry or the comedy business or
nothing to do with arts yeah man my
husband man he what he deserves a
Hawaiian vacation yeah we all do guys
man
you see them it's insane the step they
asked for you know and you're like hey
dude get a job man I'm out here working
seven days a week no money making no
money I know I thought I were I notice
you could type ask for a grant or
something man get out of here dude
[ __ ] vacation or sometimes you know
they recycle amen you can read the
10,000 oh I figured let's see how far
they can go another ten yeah yeah Grady
you start seeing the people who donated
money and it's some of your friends and
you're like you don't want to say
something they brought a man ate a
doctor kid doctor doctor can doctor care
you know donated $500 let me tell you
something man
keep your money it's crazy
he was on an f1 meet yeah man for my
accident bro no never did that man what
happened I got one thing I used patreon
for the podcast if they want to donate
because my goal would be to do a podcast
with no ads you know and then it would
be the people spot yeah how about their
full-time commercial you had people like
you man I like Davidson and then he had
one I mean we had a cool one though oh
yeah absolutely shot you know guys that
and the you know guys that are out said
stuff that I like that I actually used
the rail ices leather booze made
personally made thousand a thousand
handmade from a kid 24 years old
downtown
Hispanic
kid man you know this guy's incredible
cobbler 24 years old no but I you know I
had him on the podcast because I like
these dudes table you got tell me the
name
oh yeah Brian the boot maker and this
kid look I'm wearing right now you know
a guy makes both he does this guy's 24
years old making boots by hand it's a
rarity about the place there's an old
run-down place had been in downtown LA
there since the 30s he bought the joint
and he started from customizing Jordans
at high school for kids like I could
customize your Jordans I can change
colors and stuff you know I used to
customize bands yeah yeah man you to
wear bad new a little oh yeah get that
bottom if I handed I had to work two
dogs out of Milan's on that [ __ ] it
wasn't just like here over here get two
pairs whenever you want my parents never
let us work bro we're looking for a job
or how to do anything bro uh what time I
had a job like somebody talked to us
amen you don't want to make two horns on
a date and I said [ __ ] yeah what we
gonna do you gotta stand over there son
store in south star maps Oh star maps I
was only planning my money bro where I'm
gonna spend it I was a real deal about
what celebrities invite me to their
house and you know I thought gonna stand
right there and make money bro yeah mom
said no we don't trust it we don't know
this guy
imaginable kidnapped there's some star
map the movie and I think I'm I'm glad
they're doing it I had a [ __ ] job I
remember like when I was young where you
would go door-to-door and sell magazine
subscriptions oh the worst you know just
cold rings that's tough man because you
don't have the magazine on you look at
this great deal on time life or maybe
you like you know it's illustrate how
doors nobody slowly okay no you don't
like you're just like for a month and
you got like five bucks it's almost like
comedy
bring fun Oh Matt can never do that
daughter doing stuff like oh my god
there's a kid it's like crowd work crowd
work man as I care no he talks about
this but I used to work for junior
careers yeah I would hate to have a
little this time plastic box you could
buy a home at Home Depot and they were
full of tea cookies and candles and I
would go to door to door and go hello my
name is Felipe and I'm trying to win a
trip a camping trip and a Disneyland
trip you know I could be out there you
know in gangs but I'm trying to stay
away from gangs so I work with junior
career while I live and that didn't work
I shut the door man whoo so sometimes
man I would just lay out all my products
and then open the door and tell him make
him look huh I got I'll tell you the
scariest story ever had I had a paper
route and you used to have the paper rub
Bobby Hill man Bobby Hill on a Skyway
and you would have to collect the money
at the end of the month anyway and they
would hide from me you can see him in
there they like turn the TV down and
[ __ ] so this one time I was collecting
and the guy opened the door he had a
tracheotomy the hole in the neck I'd
never seen that he's like come on and
the little flat blew open you know have
like a napkin or some [ __ ] yeah it was
like a weird old saw that guy got the
paper free brutal man walking bomb yeah
do you get the phone tobacco or what
some Oh candy that's however only
disagreed yeah no I've never heard of a
case you know what I said you know they
got a new lady doing the commercial now
like smoking took my day and I was like
what what's the audition right that
format just like 80 of those women in
there I'm better I got a better hole I
wonder how she got that she wants to
miss mowcher with eight huh little I
went to the coal mine a lot of people
old school people sort of smoking when
they're like teenagers do yeah I smoked
it as a teenager you're a smoke I'm sort
of a fun meet you smoke yeah well it's a
fund me and then go harder go
yeah go fund me go find me and keep on
me yeah go fund me go for me the
companies in the world are the scams of
all of them get straight up like the
check-cashing joy I think it's more it's
more than I became look it up here now
that's what's called a wreck it huh
that's crazy though right like hey let's
just start a company where we just make
money off people's donations takes money
to make money doc so all this money
everybody who's donating to these
GoFundMe decide you just keep the money
how much money they'll have a grip or if
you don't reach your goal they don't
give it to you right yeah yeah does it
return does it refund back to the people
I believe so only Kickstarter whoa
that's a scam so these fools come up
twice in I don't know anything about
that [ __ ] I don't belie you know what I
want to see a documentary on window when
the people do Bitcoin that's great the
secret that shit's crazy but when the
people reach their goal go see if they
actually use the money for what they
said they were doing like just go you
know what I mean like oh we're doing
this art thing for our school and
everything and then the guys got a new
Camaro you know that's the documentary I
want to say remember bregma day the high
school I read oh yeah I read one where
these hipsters in Brooklyn or somewhere
wherever the battery in New York
somewhere yeah no chance to Kickstarter
because they were start their own
supermarket to get local stuff you know
they need like organic stuff you know
and then and I know it wasn't my type
I'm gonna donate a dollar just leave a
comment and I say [ __ ] you and your
market
hahaha no why don't you just go to the
local bodega guy and ask him can you
please go buy almond milk yeah can you
go please go buy some organic stuff can
you change your market to feed the needs
of this community nice today I will tie
my own market and get rid of the bodega
[ __ ] you [ __ ] and put
puts them on a busy just clarify your
[ __ ] needs on gentrify your ass piece
of [ __ ] angry you know that said it not
that close bro really in Boyle Heights
damn yeah it was a popular Mexican rest
of the only two twice before where do
you live now for eBay
I'm Granada Hills Granada Hills oh yeah
brother living a bastard on heroes
Mission Hills work with it Granada Hills
up there I don't know man you know
that'll be far bro I'm taking back dogs
I take it back to lambreaux from the for
the Catholics I live right I like
walking distance from the San Fernando
mission Wow never Starbucks in their
same Starbucks so you see that's why
should I go for crazy stalker fans tell
you bro live Trevor and you know who I
am
also will you live uh-oh that's the
weirdest right no that's my friend's
house we get jumped off a block before
my house yeah you stop me right here bro
drop off at their little house that's it
yeah I live in this real real dark house
right here bro with no grass I mean you
meet people man that you know that me no
no other people that I made it one of
his homeboys
yeah the tractor named Andy yeah yeah
the guy Australia you guys on Sons
anarchie now he's driving uber yeah
that's how this town works people think
a he's on a show for a season the Irish
guy from the monarchy oh really yeah the
Irish season remember they throw them
over there off the out there building
yeah they're at the end of the season
it's awesome but that's how this
business man you know like you think
you're that guy's got to be rich he did
a season of Sons an arcade and now he's
driving uber yeah went glitz on the
glory
it's [ __ ] rough ride man hell yeah
man I say okay locals I saw your BET's
comicview man
no man get the order please yeah I
remember when I had to be credit back in
97 bro 97 98 yeah and now I'm still
working at Dodger Stadium and I was
taking somebody's order you're 40 man
man you like an inspiration bro yeah man
what would you like job three hot dogs
and two beers all right man cuz here ID
and then that they now have a little tip
jar right there bro you thought I'd - I
had to give him the money bro I used to
uh relate to hand people back the money
yeah I will not call my tip jar that
signal and then it would make sure they
always have dollars bro yeah and then
like and then later round bro they give
me a little tip jar and if I like him
brought Sona bro coming back bro and
give me $3 imma give you free refills
refill for $3
yeah that's the way to go man you get
you know take it take it from the
Dodgers right hey when you threw the
first pitch you should have said this is
for all the scams I did out here the
O'Malleys of the McCourt's oh yeah I
should take hundreds of hot dogs home
bro dude every day really everything
they'll be like like East our stand with
double stands so we would have like at
least like 30 hot dogs left over every
night and you had to give them back to
the arm believe it bro the armitron know
the people that the company we work for
it was a Marriott yeah at the time I
don't know who is it now it's okay norm
Aramark Aaron mark fool you take all
those hot dogs back and then when you
turn in the money they add everything up
all the empty clubs to make sure
everything's matches and they match the
overage to those hot dogs and then they
get those hot dogs to the mission and
the mission it takes them to the other
mission Wow
but when you're not allowed to take the
food home right but food always take
food home yeah yeah I really caught
these two old lady with four two boxes
for the hot dog for years old [ __ ]
[ __ ] had a hefty bag full of hot dogs
yeah lying uh who's she gonna feed dog
dogs
hey did I give the old ladies a boot
nobody
probation after they after they fire
after they caught it bro
they made it that everybody has to have
a see-through backpack I see and then
you guys were like [ __ ] you grannies so
everybody had a see-through backpack
blue sea I did take your bags on the way
out [ __ ] all that I'll be eating at work
welcome I drove Foster Friess I would
eat all day in there I I first show up
right dr. freezoid yeah the first one
the first would be 3:30 my right when I
punch in soon as the manager would split
I'd be a full-on ice cream sundae I
don't have bomb-ass banana shakes you
did the rake covered it to work bro
let's do it all the old fight of the
wave row like Judge Reinhold in [ __ ]
our passive observer half shudder signal
fries before his time fresh fries and
they by the end of the night I would
have like three burgers in me easily a
Sunday you know onion rings at all and
people hero fast-food worker but we good
oh yeah and then I'd make my own [ __ ]
like oh yeah your own [ __ ] that will you
made it was good I'll tell you what I'm
a Dodger Stadium bro I I made this
before the Carl's jr. had and I had the
famous story the del razor it's just the
burger that's onion rings on it and then
nacho cheese you know like you know just
cheese yeah this [ __ ] was great my
friend
I definitely uncle didn't beef at the
time but my friend Ivan that food will
get a hotdog bro yeah and then put up
cherry Aki beef over it bro Yeah right
and then put teriyaki over it and [ __ ]
and then put chicken more teriyaki
teriyaki Donna bombs to naughty dog bro
that was just a halt like that pizza the
meat lover one he'd throw some foods bro
I didn't know his old man eating it well
[ __ ] bro he was working there for years
therefore used to UM just grab the
hotdog bun and food I was not with them
Yoshinoya beef
and then put not to cheese over it all
that's made of Philly Yoshi noise yeah
that's like a ghetto Philly Philly
Philly no Co all that food at Dodger
Stadium sucks man
yeah like I remember they were like the
Dodger dog wait you have and I had it I
was like this is terrible
but you talk about with a dog a dog but
what Stan you buy it well for you didn't
I tell you what kind of hot you got
you're sitting a pavilion bro right if
your left field they don't [ __ ] around
over there's too many people they steam
them Wow girly come on bro like remember
at the liquor store and though the hot
dogs they're painting hanpan you're
spinning that's the kind of outdoor you
got yeah but see if you went down
stepping on play bro when I used to work
those dogs when you buy them they crunch
that's the [ __ ] right to have a we
didn't have a hot dog
leave our place a little unless they had
a bird mark and burned pink burned pink
[ __ ] that's the way and it was and it
was and we used to boil them and beer
first
so the floor we had we had a container
at Dodger Stadium that we have to fill
up with half beer really an excellent
and water and then like it's its boilie
running on top of the grill and then we
put all our hot dogs in there first and
then what a while the grill is heating
up the water is heating up and then
we'll start splashing the hot dogs on
top of the grill and then pin it like
that dog [ __ ] technique right there
Rockman all those kids just eaten beer
dogs wrestle soft and crunchy that's
what we could burn them cuz they already
cooked from the inside right even though
our wieners already cooked but you know
it's been tough me but at Pavillion Dean
Del Ray let me tell you whoa those
[ __ ]
yeah come out like dick nasty I used to
go out here that one area where you pay
one price you could eat as much as you
guys grill dodge it other streams
so those hotdogs kebab roll circumcise
hey I'm gonna knock on boiled dogs that
[ __ ] him up - yeah my mom I swear the
guy that's the only way she made [ __ ]
house door bless her soul
yeah she knew how to make Mexican food
but American food forget about it she
will put like all the hot Dodger dogs
the little wieners from farmer John in a
boiling pot bro oh nasty
just like hot Bologna yeah thanks to
like what my mom did was shoot the shop
up cuz you know we couldn't eat hot dogs
could we're like seven kids bro they
don't have hot dogs in that pack oh yeah
so a mom will grab all the hot dogs and
put her hand on top of them and start
slicing them up and then cook them up
and then get like six seven or eight
eggs and put it on top with onions and
cheese and jalapeno that's how we ate oh
no poor man's chorizo oh yeah I've
always liked weenies up with eggs I like
you know what I like that you go to
Pink's and you get the [ __ ] spicy
polish that thing I'll light your face
on fire I've had that [ __ ] right
yeah man you could tell man they cooked
out that thing you know I'm be here but
I know bro could you bite it pow yeah
that's now absolutely and here's the
tears that with time to go to Pink's no
one ever talks about this but between
four and seven you can't park on that
Street so you get there right around 15
to 4 and no one's there there's no line
it's always like three people and you
can just grab a dog real quick and get
out of there and a no dumbass line if
you think I've been in labor more than
ten years yeah you learn the tricks
sixteen years
we hang out with a drummer from Motley
Crue bro bass player give me a little
drumroll
you know baseline was so fool man
everyone time man so you started off in
bands right yeah you were to go Singler
yeah saying 25 years playing me as a
vocalist vocalist I'm yeah I really
wanna tell you that you wallflowers yeah
toured with The Wallflowers for a year
ten months
hold that that was cray man it was like
that's when I knew it was over with me
here to mean like I did one last big
tour and I go I'm out you know because
it was so good and that was like the
kind of the end of the rocker and people
are just stealing music yeah
imagine Felipe at age I always compared
to people they go I could he steal music
they go yeah like I asked comedians and
I go what if you worked on something for
a year your bits and then a guy just
shot a special with all your bits would
you be mad [ __ ] Helen Pierce arms has
the same thing on stereo sound but they
steal the recordings
okay now this one you say that because
I'm throw the time word I don't know if
Walgreens or doing like two three bands
that had the same song I think I showed
him a Howard Stern only similar tune Oh
st.
yeah same well a lot of songs sound the
same you know which is weird
it's like you know it's like Osama free
music oh now I'm talking you were giving
it away then no when people would just
steal it you know on Napster yeah Eli
bro did you would you have like were you
a solo dude or did you have a band
called no deen dayal rain but i had band
guys maybe it's on i tech pay off iTunes
finally I'm making money I got to see I
got it for my birthday
it just I got your present
as you in the back I play a little
guitar and the cover it's blue yeah
that's it and were you under the
wallflowers tour when they were blowing
up with that song no that that after
that after that but you know like
wallflowers I always compared a lot of
bands like they had huge records and
then and then people just lose track
they goes that band still around it's
like yeah man they're hot they're
[ __ ] killing it with records
Springsteen just called
Jakob Dylan one of us
top 10 song writers of all time you know
like favorites for him so I mean when
Springsteen is dropping your name last
week you're still in the game you know
what like Roku that banner thinks it was
all yellow to Cokely Cokely I did like
four days of math on myself on coal
plate Wow my house bro
I make ceviche dog well I clean the
corners of my house bro I was crying aw
I don't know oil going through bro I
wrote I wrote like Charles Bukowski bro
but say my [ __ ] didn't make sense you
trying to be a day date right Mathur I
did everything right we're gonna hammer
and I [ __ ] made a hole in my wall and
I said I wrote my dreams are in there
now that album I played over and over
and over abroad with my record was he
was losing my mind
no not the one that has yellow the next
one after that next one it's great that
our bullshitter came with suicide pills
perish perish
oh man that is definitely like don't
break up with someone and then start
listening yeah
take yourself out yeah man that's when I
was going through that little time man
thinking about everything bro finances
where I'm gonna be out of ten years
where's the Rope where's the rope
yeah you were on the ropes that record
is get you going like I cannot listen to
those songs without knowing every bad
thing I've done in a four day when I
listen to it oh man I remember brings
brings it back off vivid yeah Mel we're
gone bro
King Cole played lesser wasting are
denied or smoking it nah bro smoking is
for losers bro thanks nerd I like
getting that power in the back your head
that's the only good part of [ __ ]
I did it's time I did it man
oh there silver league yeah and we're
playing Pompeian
it's the card game yeah and I also read
oath freebasing know what smoking crack
but I ran out oh I'll do one of those II
you know son I - I was like clear -
while we're not doing nothing
yeah and I did it bro and it felt like
somebody hit me with a basketball my
nose it's unbelievable not like hey oh
and then when I start coming down the
throat or tasted it is like [ __ ] tastes
and tastes like Coke it tastes like just
like like somebody like a like if you
let an aspirin dissolve in the backyard
row like just an aspirin just threw it
in your mouth like but tell you what bro
smoking it lasts longer yeah yeah I
never smoked it I did it like I did one
bump and that [ __ ] last me 12 hours bro
I was up brother know what to do bro
yeah yeah I just had this guy on my show
recently and I hadn't done that [ __ ] in
20 years but he was shown I'd be scared
to do it but this guy showed me the new
meth it is he's like he's yeah he's
glass or was he said yes it's like that
[ __ ] it looks like a diamond and it's
rock hard and he said it's like
state-of-the-art meth meth this [ __ ] is
like he said you know weed is crazy now
mm-hm think we'd 20 years ago it was
good but it wasn't like this that's what
the meth like and he showed it to me I
was like wow the kind now beyond he said
like he gave a guy a little bump the guy
was up to day it's like when am I going
to sleep two days what now imagine bro
they were giving meth to all the slaves
almost cartoon we would have had who
ramped up production dude I know I
brought that up because I was in Alabama
and I passed by a cotton field that was
a meth flashback yeah Mel with a foot
for truckers anyways man this weekend
I'm gonna be
Tucson Arizona I'm doing Fort Huachuca
Fort Huachuca with finesse Mitchell if
you have an active military card or
you're an employee of the US Army you
were welcome to come to the show and
that's my message right now you're doing
heroin I smoked it but I never shot it
smoked morphine morphine yeah like opium
with a white powder I was brown all you
at the blonde one yeah you know off the
foil wow man you don't use only gonna do
it once yeah one time me too in
Amsterdam and LA - I'm not like down I
was always into up me to me I want to be
up they I don't understand when people
around me were we were doing coke and
we're drinking and somebody goes who
want to eat kill that guy please yeah we
ought to be healthier I know give me a
burrito [ __ ]
I was so into I like when you're up a
couple days like straight man your brain
is in another land you're just kind of
like you and you're like good going a
liquor store run and you're around
normal people oh man that is weird
right you're just I've been up two days
you're in there with a case of you're
honest all right sir covers the issue of
people you know you're not supposed to
talk to but isn't that weird though when
you're out in the real world and you're
all spun out you don't know that I'm
like I felt a vampire bro and a vampire
like a vampire should be sleeping yeah
yeah you can't stand the Sun oh man I
used to call it racing the Sun you gotta
get home before that [ __ ] comes up you
know crazy the heroin hell no don't be
live now what's actually like I don't
know man like it's like I'm being high
but like super stoned or what for stone
yeah and sleepy but you feel motivated
too though you wanna do nothing to me
it's like the ground is metal and you're
you're like a magnet you're just like oh
I'm good here did you throw up by the
way I didn't throw up man I just I
actually smoked it in a blues club this
guy was like hey let's watch this [ __ ]
proper I got some opium here I said when
people say a proper is on bro yeah and
said we smoked some in the bathroom and
they came back out and watch these guys
play the Blues in the Tenderloin and San
Fran for like an hour just out of it
like you're from the bay yeah you
mention tenderloin brought me to a
tenderloin has not changed no that's the
only neighbor they can't gentrify it
can't ride and why is that you would
have to like burn it down to the ground
and start over just to get rid of the
rats and the roaches and they yeah
they're never they'll never clean that
up what was originally at the
tenderloins in San Francisco oh that was
it a blue-collar area people worried
docks what that blue that things always
been the terrible neighborhoods good
roar yeah even when it was blue like San
Fran in the 70s was blue-collar no one
wanted to live there they wanted to live
in Mill Valley and Walnut Creek [ __ ]
like that so all the you know the
blue-collar people lived in Sam friend
of the plumbers the electricians and
everything and and it was this great
city you know but that was always
terrible that in Hunters Point
those were the two ghettos and and then
the mission was a little shady but now
everything's a million dollars but still
the Tenderloin
Mikey you know Ren is like five grand
for a one-bedroom there right now you
know that time we were there we were
walking around with Burma and Chris
Doering his girlfriend yeah yeah brother
Tenderloin bro right here let's go don't
like easy people like walking around
people talking to themselves yeah got a
shuttle boxing one time that dude was
going off with that lock yeah yeah I was
just there recently I saw a guy and we
just was parking and the guy was trying
to light a building on fire with a Bic
lighter it's a hot light this place on
fire like what are you doing dude that's
my daddy was I'm gonna burn my old place
to the ground it's concrete
he's got a lighter up on the [ __ ] and a
full a torch into a new the mitchell
theaters yeah yeah all that neighbor
there's this great [ __ ] in that
neighborhood the great American Music
Hall yeah that's a [ __ ] masterpiece
there dude you know like all the great
bands have played there
and in comedy they've done comedy in
there there's a place once you leave
that area what it is but let this it's
in the corner and there's like a big
arcade and they have hamburgers and
stuff but and it's like there's pictures
outside of it
big arcade yeah I don't know it it's
like a big arcade and anything and
probably they tell freak shows there huh
I don't know that spot sauce made up
there yeah I remember the green door bro
yeah and then they made into a movie and
they green doors to a liberal yeah I
tell you what they I think after that
deep throat now after the earthquake
does when that city changed the 89
baseball game you know Candlestick Park
days huh well what happened was what's
that bridge collapsed and [ __ ] then
people are like I'm moving out of here
you know yeah and and then people bought
that place pennies on a dollar and then
started raising the rent you know it's
[ __ ] that thing if people were afraid
but I went to building funny on my
imagine what 60 minutes on Sunday and I
watch this show on mr. Sunday yeah it's
the one yeah it's great there's a
building in San Fran you can watch it
called the Millennial building
it's the highest skyscraper there and
they built it like five years ago Joe
Montana bought a place in there all
these billionaires but you know five
million-dollar condos in there
it's sinking and falling to the left
like this thing's [ __ ] sinking
because they skipped on using iron they
went concrete and it's sinking into the
sand and you know this thing could fall
man it's like a hundred stories Luther
his heart Oh bro yeah going soft need
some male building scary though man were
so full of jiggle Yeshua's coming up or
what
no not this week I mean I'm gonna be
doing spots I'll open my tonight but I
know but shout out to those dudes in
Riverside dude I'm at the theater when'd
you start doing stand-up comedy cuz we
made at that we made on Thanksgiving one
time I thought that the Christmas
giveaway next is one eight years next
eight yes what you started we were your
first but at the Hollywood improv it was
one of their shows this guy was putting
on it was like so you want to do comedy
it's like a bringer show you know but it
was like you know they're like a doctor
they have like a mom and you know then
like me you know people that wanted to
try it it was sold out totally sold out
you know because everybody brings all
their friends and that was December 6
are you a pay regular at The Comedy
Store yeah yeah why'd you we'll try out
well I was there for three years and
then I got past the joy audition you're
like no what happens is you're doing
that potluck over and over and over
watching you that way like Mitzi wasn't
there once I started coming around okay
when I started Mitchie saw me for nine
weeks in a row
I would like I would do three minutes
and I would I would she shouldn't even
speak to me she would I was somebody
third-party told me she was tell
somebody tell Philippe to come back next
weekend doing or three minutes
so then he would tell me um machiste to
come back next week I don't know three
minutes so there for nine weeks and then
on the eighth week she said I'm miss you
want you to do ten so they're ten yeah
and then on the tenth week she reached
over and grabbed my arm and she said I'm
calling four spots tomorrow badass
what's up fool that's old-school man
that didn't help to a person in her
voice because she straight-up told me
call for spots
so I call for spots and then I realized
that man is it [ __ ] empty bro oh that
[ __ ] bro I'll come forward a couple of
spots I got some of the latter to put
the letters up [ __ ] quit the next day
oh man
you were doing the a marquise marquise
bro everybody did I guess and I worked
the door in the back I would take off my
white t-shirt and go to a set and come
back never get pierce bro oh yeah Oh cuz
you took the shirt off
no keep my shirt off and left the post
by itself and we'll do a spot Oh
nobody's there right yeah he goes that
way I'll go up and I'm still my our
window the white Comedy Store t-shirt
how og I was right yeah the one with the
ring ring yeah man sleeves yeah me a
fluffy had those shirts you know you
don't go on there much no ma'am always
busy man like more than the road or I
have a meeting but I did I'm a show last
I saw either stone yeah yeah this guy
ler of the audience comedy show we never
had a showcase with my own agency
maverick and showcases yeah and whatever
show I'm on I show up now you didn't
come for spots because now I'm just
gonna gather if I don't get a spot that
week I take a personal and I won't call
again now what do you do you just go on
the road and do the weekend and then
come home and don't do comedy midweek no
I come home I'm gonna come today oh I
gotta do this podcast uh-huh I have to
do my acting class on Tuesdays from 7-8
and I have a meeting every day every
meeting or somebody because y'all fools
check this out remember I had to tell it
that the ABC deal uh and ABC didn't want
to shoot the pilot now I found out from
Bobby and Peter that they're gonna be in
the waiting for ABC to release it so Fox
could get a chance to look at the new
pilot Wow you got a pilot Who am I gonna
go ahead a second year so my get a
second deal another year of money to not
work the tube but I'm pretty sure Don
Fox was in love with it bro when we left
the parks meeting I'll never forget this
was a lady's hand on a table
sold Wow she did a cold she said sold we
could do it this guy we could do it here
at Fox I love these guys I'm below with
the pitch huh
she didn't want to change nothing Wow so
when we went to park ABC it became work
family-orientated show I'm pretty sure
when we go to a fox we're gonna get rid
of half of the family bro there's gonna
be just two brothers you got you got a
white beard in the pilot hell yeah bro
he was a clean-cut guy married to my
sister but if I get cut off to what I'm
right here money a tire guy might need a
cooter oh wow so Hazzard cooter brah
akattak oh yeah that's me
that's that's a dream role where you
only have two or three we're all nines
and Winkies come in like you want to
touch my tool and then you walk out and
you're a tool fool tell you bro Martin
my Rachel Martin yeah bro man in Rome el
gesto yo mangani catch up and then leave
bro go sell our shows and Tommy T's
right health care you know what I mean
two spots that's it that's why I love my
row on superstore bro Cody yeah
I showed my little blue jumpsuit see
Milo stupid as I leave bro hello
applause break that's awfully before
that thank you very much
I did love this year it's coming at
season three and in March and you know
you go down there this was even better
like Judd Apatow is just like I go you
got some lines you got snide you just
riff you'll be good and it was great I'm
just riffing stuff on every scene like
how great is that what is love
love's a killer show on Netflix Manny's
on it well it's about a hipster couple
man but it's really funny I sit here no
way yeah you would love it they live in
silver who throws the show well there's
like there's like three stars like yeah
it's great it's great
so check out Dean doughy I love funny
this shows I think it's one of the
funniest shows I've seen a lot like you
live in LA so you watch it you're loving
I love any show that stayed in LA and
they show oddly
yeah like [ __ ] I'm East lows high
love it yeah [ __ ] alley oh [ __ ] it's
no far [ __ ] hunter TJ TJ hunter yeah
TJ Hooker TJ Hooker and the other guy
was Ali hunter right just hunter and of
course I'm ISA insecure they show
Inglewood up to no good
oh yeah I was thinking about that was
that was the hammer film in LA
oh yeah don't forget chips that'd be
funny of you and I did a new chips well
you'll be funny Billy chunks also need
the Ray in the D razors bro
yeah tell razor Snow razors now I'm
gonna be in New York this Comedy
Festival this week yeah tell them rule
yeah Friday and Saturday with Joey Diaz
we're at the at the Gotham but it sold
out but then after that I'm like 20
nights at the stand so come out Stan
we're gonna be [ __ ] dancing on ice 29
it's gonna be good Iron Maiden in the
race to like handle to the song
how great is that
[Music]
right what did I saw peachy folders
what's up
Wallabies extra soles dirt Derby Jackie
Jack [ __ ] Levi jacket with a four
[ __ ] oh yeah
3434 to know ever everybody had that
warm fat stoner chick yeah that word
that leave my jacket no matter where
what whether it was also lady ass [ __ ]
doing hickey that's insane needs to be
these two girls and they were homies and
they were lesbians but at the first
lesbian I ever met and they were [ __ ]
pot heads and stoners bro and one of
them
she wore a denim jacket and denim jeans
and [ __ ] converse and she was skinny
brochure like hi Rivera and the other
one was fat bro just a fat chick bro and
man those [ __ ] to [ __ ] who's up Wow
don't start drinking with fools and then
jack on bro robbers I had this girl in
junior high I had this down jacket and
for some reason this girl had the same
one it was red with blue up here that
was a hot couple years was down jackets
were hot member and she was smoking
cigarettes and burned hers and begged me
to trade right please my parents they're
gonna if they find out I smoked and I
was like
I don't want to get in trouble for
smoking either you know and they'd had a
hole in it was just blowing out feathers
I gotta go down every meet ha you know
what I mean they're like [ __ ] junior
high you don't want to be busted for
smoking Helen out of hats on it
I don't assume you knows you're in high
school man though I'm sorry no junior
high school bro the most my pot heads in
a world where that your new high school
yeah I mean [ __ ] were smoking
some horrible weed back there see yes
seeds right here popping hell yeah
that's funny you say that Maywood man
you smoking a joint boy like you talking
marshmallows yeah yeah yeah the seeds
would pop maybe that so you sober you
don't drink at all I don't drink at all
I smoked some weed once in a while but
you know I'm 51 man I did it I'm good
yeah I mean I'm not done I mean you know
why was believed here cuz your
references are from the same era as I
was you were like name and the house of
whiskey please
backwards Oh our table or did you go my
friend today did you go [ __ ] no bro my
party with that [ __ ] music this fools on
stage
dude that's who the roadie bro that's my
favorite time I'm trying to do a
documentary on it
you should broke start with me brother
guy who quit it who couldn't go Yeah
right I'm in where people yeah name the
[ __ ] heavy metal band they were their
triumphs
ozzie guillen band was Quiet Riot oh my
with Randy wrote Randy Rhoads plain
Aussie this is a this is a Quiet Riot
with [ __ ] Rudy Sarzo Carlos Cavazos
oh yeah and then the next band was
Motley Crue right before shout at the
devil came out they had those killer
claws and then the next band weirdo
tucked Tommy hit the head here I gotta
go here like a [ __ ]
gun gun thing right like a [ __ ]
bullets bullets yeah yeah I think that
with no t-shirt on and then you have
next up was Ozzy first gig with Jackie
Lee bark at the moon
then you got then you got tribe
everybody went and took a piss then
scorpions
van Halen Darryl there's your lineup and
you know what I got the ticket stub I
Instagram it every year on that day it
was twenty dollars twenty five twenty
five Wow thirty dollars huh yeah I was
caught I was close for a few of the
bands but you'd go in and out there was
like you know what almost a million
people at that festival even the new
wave one was amazing oh yeah I was row
of the new wave okay the new wave one
Bowie headlock yes David Bowie on the
Duran Duran missing-persons [ __ ] uh
boinga-boinga-boinga but what's the guy
man at work and they were then four
casinos who met at work
had to help the player with a bigger
better that than the the first day was
the best though as far as like historic
is it was the clash they had lined with
like stray cats and all those but the
class that's the last gig with their
lineup though the new one right no that
was like the the new owner or the one to
those country right that was the fourth
day I didn't go to that that was like a
money there was a punk rock one that's
right there was a punk lash it was like
stray cats I got it I got it in my phone
it's uh but the clash was the headliner
so the headliners were the clash the
next day van Halen the next day David
Bowie yeah Warren they're probably no
foreigner I wish sticks no sticks sticks
is good right ghost in the machine
some better that's police the police
yeah I thought that was [ __ ]
foreigner no with the ghost of the
machine no that's foreigner had head
games dirty white boy yeah go to the
machine how do they go well that's the
name of the record Oh
oh yeah
so did already Leo Sayer tattoo I gotta
piss
alright go bro with you one bro with
that BTS bad connected away he's a
beggar we throw yeah you're gonna put
him in there every now and then we even
forgot to introduce some waffle we don't
need he's dean terrain a man need no
introduction
okay later gentlemen what dinner is
taking a long P and peeing blood over
their upcoming shows November 10 Fort
Huachuca Arizona also I'm hosting the
Tropic alia Music Festival in Long Beach
at Queen Mary Park Harbor November 11 on
my birthday we might think everybody her
November 15 Aberdeen Proving Ground
Maryland November 16th Fort Belvoir
Virginia November 17th Fort Hamilton New
York
November 18th Fort Drum New York
November 22nd I'm in Midland Texas
coming to New York City in Portland
Oregon Atlanta Georgia in Austin Texas
and a bunch of other cities next year
with the bad decision tour also Rodrigue
will be joining me during the bad digits
all right he'll be there at all the
shows so you can hit them up tell them
what's up we're going to all these days
well G gonna be there and we're gonna
add a different feature tag at different
spots make sure to get your tickets now
a few VIP meeting greet tickets left for
most of those cities checkout Phillipos
WorldCom's last tour for our ticket
information and links and mam food you
know for drum new york that base is
their army base it it's in numb by a new
brooklyn really that yeah it's like on
the underside of brooklyn it was made
during during the civil war
really yeah man cuz i'm that porch port
drum well one of the first during the
during the american revolution or food
the british troops took over that place
so they want that should happen again
where they just come into the ocean the
bottom of new york so that's why Fort
Drum New York is there
Fort Huachuca Fort Huachuca Arizona bad
Adam that fort was made because they
were afraid of Apache attacking him um
Geronimo really so Geronimo with our
tent was I took that wood it's on a
patchy land it was a man even though
Apaches bro they owned from here from
Arizona to Chihuahua bro and and Sonora
all that [ __ ] yeah that's where most
Mexicans are Apaches are they're not um
I'm sure there's some blood I mean [ __ ]
trace it back and go to ancestry.com but
you know pinched Karissa's pinched
Apache toccata most Mexicans table when
they said when so much has to act white
or touch to act not Mexican yeah look at
you bro you have enough kind of kind of
the Apache like you're the facing of
Apache talk about that [ __ ] calm down
you Comanche but at the same time in my
house is dirty my mom stays but it cuz
of the induced this house
Native Americans live here who's right
or wrong
and my mother looks Native American dog
I maybe see my mouth old pictures she
loved Japanese bro I know in my her dad
my grandfather he danced tribal dancers
need to put beads on his legs and bees
and his wrists and be like Shh
tell Mexico there's still a lot of
natives oh yeah bro like if you're
Mexican you're Mexican if you're home if
you're funded if America to Mexico it's
like being redneck huh pretty much she
suits you I love Mexico well part bro
East LA that's pretty good man it's
coming up it is Echo Park amazing oh yes
you own that pad no did I make nine
dollars a month you go to the house
where did your podcast but I'm a badass
please oh man oh yeah I lost that place
though you do own a house now fact now
it's just renting and then we own that
whole place now I was renting the whole
huge place notice that's the part you
were in oh that was to death the house
dude yeah that wasn't like the podcast
a little flat my bad I thought I thought
for some reason that the whole house was
huge and I saw many rooms no I mean
you're hallucinating man you you were
you were just in the one real cat no you
wore the kiss shirt Dodger Stadium kiss
sure I remember that part bus you
mention no it was the guest housing
management all right you're still a nice
room though Wow impressed yeah else's
mansion in the guest asset it's like
you're at a great neighborhood you
wouldn't be able to afford I mean do you
have updates coming up this weekend or
the following week shows okay I'm gonna
go watch York all month at the stand and
then Sacramento Joey Diaz and I come in
December 8 9 10 punchline yeah ray it
with the del razor yeah I gonna be do
the whole week and headline Sunday when
Joey is not there no should me that you
should do that but it's like I've rather
get in and out of there and then come
back and head I had line that collab on
my own like once and once a year but
since he was going I was like oh I need
something like I don't got anything a
December you know it's like slow
December in January I always suck for me
every year VM I'm dead um you should be
like summer broke two weeks all of June
actually recharge yeah oh yeah look at I
want to it just happened that way I
remember we did that gig together you
and I it was so funny I love it and that
place was always empty and then you did
it and sold it out all three tiers
that's what it was like ac/dc
thunderstruck video or whatever
everybody looking down it was incredible
and the haha cafe got mad cause he
missed a spot
oh yeah that's right I was that's right
they did you got a good memory on that
for a STONER
I told him how I remember you were
trying to leave oh [ __ ] - how much they
pay you nothing stay here yeah
I didn't stayed there best tip you gave
me hello we're numb Hollywood doing a
podcast Oh
five and a half years whatever so your
honor 389 gratulations thank you Dad
cuz man a lot of people started our Park
and they gave up yeah I mean and me
rodeo started out the podcast we shot
seven in a row before we put them out
there just to give us a seven-week head
start
well you know it's funny as I think
everybody's like oh you got a podcast
I'm gonna do that you know didn't know
how long it takes how much work it is
man and then yes yeah they think that
they're just gonna like doors are gonna
open I'm gonna be famous and podcasters
out and they got like nine listeners you
know the first two years I probably have
like 40 listeners but you just keep
going man it's like and you get better
at it and and you better enjoy it that's
what I tell people I enjoy it man it's
fun as hell and and when people come up
to you at the shows like a man I love
your podcast it feels so good that's the
[ __ ] right we're able to tell you man
your pot cake get me through a day yeah
I hear that all the time and then you
know you got guys that are liking in
China and it's just Africa it started in
Ireland yeah I got a guy who just
donated to the podcast he's in South
Korea man always that people from all
around the world here and it's a digital
flyer man well do your pocket would you
other Puckett yeah man right man and
people with the people let your podcast
yeah dude [ __ ] most of my like traffic
goes through SoundCloud but nevertheless
it's not rock tunes in stitcher or no
way yeah yeah yeah they picked it up so
that was kind of cool then but uh yeah
man 30 episodes it's so much work it is
man like yes right or the gas and cancel
on you you don't know crazy hard like
and me it's like I it's just me I booked
the guest I record the show I add up the
show I put it up all that so Sunday's my
whole day is in the house just getting
this thing ready and going you know and
I'm one of the one of the Parker's I'll
be like my wife and I like is that what
you got that guy from faster than
Richmond hi yeah Robert
man trouble Romani how'd you get him in
a podcast dude tell us bro we want to
know I love that I love fast tan his
brother - yeah I love fast times - movie
right so everybody knows I love it and
this guy called me one day and he goes
dude I'm down here doing an open Spicoli
at day at the cup yeah like you do his
face I can't do the voice I'm doing an
open mic here at this coffee shop and I
think one of the guys from first times
he's here and I'm like no way and he
goes yeah and it takes a picture I go
yeah
that is him what the hell so I call the
place and he answers he's like Bob's
coffee shop and I was like wow I got
goosebumps I could hear his voice you
know it's like what about the tunes have
you forgot the magnitude of Robin Zander
I'm really kind of busy right anyway I
go hey dude I want to do a podcast
through these egg whoa what's that and I
found out he owned the coffee shop so I
went down did the podcast and then Bill
burr and I did a show in there furgus oh
I got to do a show there at the open mic
and he could sell ticket he told the guy
to sell tickets and donated the money to
the guys coffee shop to keep it going
and there was like the place held like
20 and they had like 200 in there it was
great but we had a killer time and and
and Robert and I have become good
friends and he's been on twice and both
episodes were great we did a live one
with him at the improv it was killer
that guy's great he's awesome man that
was a good interview earlier for some
reason are out fishing his brother are
now he was a mean streets right here's
another stuff Vietnam for some reason
man like member Carlo I don't know wise
to the subject I was something but just
Carlo from the Godfather really yeah
yeah yeah you ever heard his story in
the Howard Stern no no you see you he
was always doing right oh my god you're
almost oh really just hit me right now
Carlo you know Carlos he was dating um
from the Godfather Connie Connie
Corleone yeah
he's a guy that I'm alone with penis on
him alone Sonny could ever beaten up and
he got choked yeah that guy that's great
my sister yeah I was glue in the wall
back and he said that he owned a
restaurant yeah all right all right he
was out night manager or whatever and uh
Colombian guy was there right Colombian
guy whatever right and um the guy was
being an [ __ ] right whatever happened
bro he put a gun out and Carl over the
real Carl killed his ass bow-wow killed
him wha what what happened was that that
guy he killed at this big Colombian drug
dealer goddamn right so now there's a
hit on this [ __ ] right so they sent
another guy there and I'm not I could be
wrong but he killed the guy too
Wow the hit man he sent after him Wow
they had to [ __ ] um yeah they may
after he killed that guy they had this
big old meeting broke because he didn't
know they're gonna cuz even though he
didn't know whether it was a mistake
Danny so I don't know if he paid for his
life or he someone representing him bro
but you could look up a Howard Stern
Wow I don't know why but I just thought
it was interesting that he's a member
right now well you know that Bob
Romano's how he got his role in fast I
was broke Wow
he was a singing waiter at some
restaurant and Ventura Boulevard
Jerry's delis I guess so yeah so he was
in there and he's just like can i and
and one of the producers is like a man I
think I might have a role for you come
down tomorrow he had to audition three
times for it man and you know he's the
lead in that movie and no one talks
about it he's in every scene and he's
the guy they never talked about but he
steals the movie every of course
everybody does Spicoli but they really
do all of his lines you know yeah man I
wouldn't crash the car yeah you can't
fix this piccoli
yeah I love that fire hey man I got
those cheap treat takers man ah that's
great
my favorite part is like I wouldn't
serve win a fire coming let's see her
twin and far nah man my favorite light
[ __ ] nerd friend forgets his wallet
bro and he calls them up yeah yeah and I
feel holds the phone in for a long-ass
time was yeah you don't wanna help with
that he come back yeah because I'm
really kind of busy red well you know
what he's watching it on that scene he's
watching Leave It to Beaver and it's the
episode where beaver stuck in the teacup
son it's great man I never seen my house
do that train ride yeah I like the
go-kart one make the [ __ ] go-kart race
I remember that one scene with buckwheat
back in the day but they took it off now
but when he was all hot anyone like this
cuz he was all sweaty anyone like this
and then the ink was on the on the wall
I'm crazy man I remember that muscle no
they don't have it they heard some [ __ ]
that Bill Cosby bought that [ __ ] then he
edit that part out
or is that [ __ ] I don't know I've
seen I sure I see masterpiece well you
know the kid hilarya lately my teacher
would put that [ __ ] out but then you
talk about an okay man book we'd the
name liberal parenting for inna
arena Saturday
buckwheat spin shot I love that
buckwheat's been shot they keep updating
it he was right out here that girl was
playing alfalfa he came right out of the
car they shot him buck weights been shot
generally when a bucket with shot you
know you know how those those secret
guards cover cover about it I mean they
like they hover about over him you know
when he got shot to cover him up one of
those guys that is all over his body
it's a guy wearing a suit and if you
paused it it's I've seen your haul
are you see yeah right ice you know how
they roll Gumby I'm Gumby damn it never
when he played Gumby who are you
Gumby damn it I swear what Brisson
stupid though was that what the the
killer trees dog
the killer trees the killer Christmas
tree I don't remember that now no okay
well with a shark attack did shark
attack
oh no that one's great Land Shark Lancer
attacking you
Land Shark oh yeah that should be not
going either one open the door
Kenny gram Chevy Chase yeah I love that
also mr. bill was great that was Joe you
know that was dan Aykroyd during that
voice I didn't know that oh man
by the way I'm one of my one of an actor
was worst movie just showed up at my
[ __ ] on it you might like this one
alright we're gonna talk to Detroit I
don't know what's with that one or the
metalheads Detroit bro Coneheads rocked
nah man dun dun dun
Oh dragna Jack dragna with Tom Hanks oh
it's good good officer now laid - what's
your movie does my foot I mean I like
when I was a kid league of their own big
shots Rat Patrol I don't know the big
shots is when one kid runs away in the
rapid termination know they grew up on
the base you know not Bratz dolls
ah but see like that shoots ahead of my
time in rabaa army brat Patrol never
heard about Brad patron ah I don't know
I came in there
nah dude like you know Stevie's got
blood sports even Seagal movies all that
a blood sport yeah but like you know all
that other stuff like I mean I like mall
rat so but that was high school area
yeah Fast Times masterpiece yeah man
yeah I did I've seen bits and pieces of
it but I never yeah oh what's your
favorite
Oh animal Hoss I caught a little bit of
that Mahalo bro and one of those things
bro where like when F who found out his
girlfriend was cheating on him bro he
showed up to her house yeah and [ __ ]
and it's how he found out his girlfriend
was cheating on him bro
Danny Danny Donald Sutherland you were
wearing one of the Big Lebowski sweaters
yeah any reaching up bro to grab a cup
of tea and you can see Donald Sutherland
white ass and when he turns around and
he [ __ ] blinks at that dude you knew
he was [ __ ] his cheek but before that
scene yeah that guy that came on Amadeus
his chillin and that guy's chilli and
his girlfriend is chilli and that Donald
Sutherland goes like a professor at that
College anybody here wanna smoke a joint
and he [ __ ] light it up and they're
all getting high dawg and then that one
of the dudes goes um okay my part of you
and the next theme is when he I'm
catching his girlfriend [ __ ] him damn
I like the scene where balloons she's
watching them [ __ ] and they get to boner
he's on the ladder and the burner pushes
him back and he eats it just remember
the food fight scene from that and then
we open around at the with a ladder blow
to door yeah yeah right
Caddyshack the best I wanted to do that
one time with no no no that's perverse a
peeping tom right yeah man - I asked
right a man the world needs dig dig dig
is - yeah now the first family that's
the first time I ever saw a movie where
white people have more than one kid Wow
because we've had the Brady Bunch they
never show like white people with a
bunch of kids I was like only a Mexican
and black was family Rocco and that's to
know them yeah but bro that should make
believe that is the Waltons come on but
Walton don't even struggle it's enough
it is enough bro I'm talking about like
the being they get big in the beginning
of the movie of Caddyshack yeah that's
worth like nine brothers oh yeah that
was a true story right Bill Murray
that's based on Bill Murray's family
yeah his brother wrote it
Bob Murray really
got there bro
are you here for the groundhog yeah Oh
bro ha
what will we bro it no matter if it's on
you're gonna watch in a hotel room
maraschino Goodfellas Big Lebowski yeah
that's a cool movie Caddyshack
Oh Lethal Weapon one know what he said
yes we got one guy John schoolyards
every time doesn't matter where it's at
I sit down and start watching jaws get
out of the water
yeah jaws is the best Burn After Reading
bro any coin on any coin movie I watch
all day long Oh [ __ ] No Country for
Old Men the masterpiece there they seen
it one time you know one time well
popped up just recently oh yeah
no country no country for old man had
movies we're not the reading boy watch
that's did a lot man super bad super bad
that's great oh brother out thou yeah
great one anything with Jews ammonia bro
easy language I like the Wes Anderson's
you know yeah I was with all day man a
moon like Kingdom more like Kingdom [ __ ]
they killed that dog man I loved that
dog Oh with an arrow shot an arrow those
look good as that's a great film Cub
Scouts reading the Cub Scouts he'll know
the gang bro yeah same thing
Cub Scouts is a gang funny we had a Cub
Scout run by Osama Dorian guy we call it
Boy Scouts Lackawanna Cub Scout so what
so for you guys girlfriend you're
married or what no man comedy is my life
that's all
cheating on you bro yeah Casino the
comics cost me a lot of money all I do
is comedy in my podcast seven days a
week an audition
that's say you don't eat sugar in
homework no I quit in 18 months ago man
Oh Oleg do you about them
how much [ __ ] sugar you eating be
like candy canes we're just gonna get up
grab a candy no matter where it's at
every day I eat candy hard candy
like sometimes I'd beaten candy and bet
you know I mean like swedish fish I'd
have a bag to you you took it off no let
me open up a candy yeah I'd say swedish
fish gummy bears
licorice the only other person that but
i never seen i didn't go your house long
enough to know yet candy but yeah so
dickey-fuller bro oh yeah I mean Kay
Lopez when I went to their house once a
couple of times they're [ __ ] the
standard dish of the of the living room
always have [ __ ] candy I mean [ __ ]
the pull of chocolates put oh grandma
candy it was always full of [ __ ]
candy no focus let's [ __ ] love sugar
and my house I never had kind of that
that's a we gon man I play your [ __ ] -
you're real sweet tooth big time like
it's so brutal I couldn't even like I
mean you know why like I quit drugs no
problem but can't you know sugar you've
been doing since you're like 5 months
old
do you know like cereals and candy and
and anything when your kid has you know
pancakes french toast
everything cause you to stop consider
beauties man more blender you actually
know I got it yeah but it's gone now
really yeah alright ray you gotta get
checked I'm good
no biggie do you feel messed up or what
oh god yeah came at it no oh
I'm lying I checked myself like what I
would live in England oh alright
two years ago but um how old are you
49 yeah yeah checked it no I took myself
two years ago they said I was fine they
found crack that's funny man but um I
thought that I'm you stop I thought
maybe had a sugar high because of the
heroin you know that other heroin
addicts when they're off heroin right
[ __ ] eating candy well when you quit
booze - because you know booze is all
sugar so you look for some other kind of
sugar and not a lot of people I remember
this one guy he quit
and he just started eating as
haagen-dazs bars everyday at like noon
and he just all sent me waited like
three 40 I was like yeah you can't
[ __ ] do that you know well so I get
you were kind of chubby huh
before that way 200 well I weighed 196
now I weigh 160 away 280 bro 280 yeah
but you're bigger than you're taller
than me yeah man I was a 300 once and
I'm gonna begin but I was gonna go back
to 265 bro or 250 maybe how do you gain
weight from being a vegan cuz most
vegans look like Ian they're like really
like crops bread bread butter flour but
today lately for the last two weeks I
have a drag of soda I'm drinking orange
juice but I haven't checked a soda
the far as I go is orange juice but may
have been craving that like when I came
into and I saw that Dr Pepper yeah and I
saw that um yeah man you know what I
drove to Pacheco or whatever that's you
know water yeah but the lime one man no
sugar and it tastes great
I'm really have a son T right here I had
one up there
oh man I can't iced coffees man don't do
me right
really I don't don't give me like a real
coffee yeah I remember two years ago
it's like you know the same like you
don't really taste it when you start
hitting it with creamer and she used to
like a black Jim when I first met Lisa
she would you get black who is this
trailer trash Trevor going through
meetings I thought she was gonna
meetings broke is there man you get the
taste of coffee but now I'd like to
taste and I could tell shitty coffee and
I'm gonna put it out there man if you
ever have a meeting with Felipe Esparza
you wanna meet me somewhere and the
coffee they made Thursday's ground
coffee I'm not gonna show up ground
works
that's the worst [ __ ] coffee in a
[ __ ] rod works sucks
this is like a new coffee shop or
something no man just a flavor man
they try to be all fancy browbone a
perfume coffee bro yeah yeah love coffee
man I'll have like three a day you know
just black coffee iced black coffee
script ready put a toasted name off I
got no dough no bread candy bread man
yeah cuz the flour turns to sugar
where'd you get your recipes and stuff
from I got a book I'll send it to you
there's a guy wrote this book he'll
raise his book I'll tell you the book
right now because what it does is it
resets your body it's called the end of
diabetes and it's an incredible book and
the guy has all kinds of tattoos lovely
bro yeah I know he looks way smaller
that when we seen you in Arizona
I haven't seen you in a long time the
ink is fading yeah it's more dude what
what's that his name is dr. Fuhrman yeah
this is a great book live is the title
of that book you know oil I reset my
whole body went vegan for two months and
then no more diabetes you know what I
mean and now I've learned how to eat you
know you when I'm on the road and then
the guy picks me up at the airport I got
stopped at Trader Joe's or Whole Foods
and I get my own [ __ ] and because you
know that's where the deadly where you
diet you're at the club it's like second
show go get the mozzarella sticks
that was my [ __ ] Dean man I swear to god
man like fried [ __ ] food at the
club right I do love mozzarella sticks
broke at san jose improv they bring up
12 of them I dip one one one dip is
monster is a marinara the next dip is
ranch or honey mustard company that I
like to order the mozzarella sticks the
fried calamari Oh as an appetizer those
two things and then of course you never
order a meal - and our nachos to go Yeah
Yeah right yeah always oh yeah you gotta
take cheese chicken tailor to go to
because the mic
in a hotel room that [ __ ] up chicken
tenders to go always oh yeah my Buffalo
going back to your Dodger days you know
taking on the dogs
hell yeah were so full check out Dean
DeRay this week at the Stan comedy club
in New York City doing the New York City
Comedy Festival and check him out at the
punchline in Sacramento with Joey COGO
Diaz right Dori that's right [ __ ]
is gonna be mean a little del razor ha
ha ha he's replacing Lisa a star of
death don't forget to check out the let
there be talk podcast too right let me
talk not let it be [ __ ] toss podcast
with don't ring honey all things comedy
network yeah man yeah man yeah I don't
know how he gets all these rock star
honey show the drummer from acid on that
was cool I just had Nikki Sixx on for
Motley Crue that was incredible we hate
him now
hello Gina long history yeah man what's
up fool they go dude in Del Ray's thanks
for having my video thank you so much
we've really touched a surfer and fool
oh I know